[Musique]
qui es-tu je ne suis personne
on te présente un nouvel ensemble de
personnages qui ont des histoires différentes
c'est la première fois qu'on découvre un
stormtrooper en tant qu'individu et c'est
ça qui brise les frontières en termes de
nouvelles idées  tout ce qui était
lié aux personnages était vraiment difficile
parce que je ne voulais pas que Finn commence dans
un sens dans le film et se termine de
la même manière que je voulais qu'il y ait beaucoup
de cœur et une transition flagrante, donc
quand il s'agissait du  scènes de dialogue
quand je découvrais Finn sans beaucoup de temps,
c'était définitivement un défi d'avoir au
moins beaucoup de personnage là-dedans quand j'ai
regardé le costume, j'ai réalisé que ce qui se
passait au-dessus du cou serait aussi
important que ce qui se passait sous le cou
et  que chaque geste que je faisais devait être
investi de quelque chose la façon dont je
marchais devait être différente de la façon
dont le capitaine phasma marchait la façon dont le
capitaine phasma courait devait être particulier
que tout devait être très spécifique
a  Et j'ai trouvé cela très libérateur, je me
sentais tellement autonome quand j'ai mis ce
costume, il semblait me dire que
c'est une femme qui est pratique parce qu'elle
porte son armure tout le temps et j'ai
pensé que c'était excitant Andy
Serkis qui  en ce qui me concerne,
c'est le père fondateur de la capture de mouvement
qu'il m'a dit quand j'ai commencé
ce film vous savez pour vous préparer à faire un
personnage de capture de mouvement vous devez faire
le travail que vous faites en tant qu'acteur il n'y a pas de
différence  vous devez savoir qui vous êtes
comment vous êtes comme vous êtes et ce que vous
voulez et vous devez aller après cela
et en plus de cela, il y a toutes ces
choses technologiques supplémentaires que vous devez
apprendre et travailler avec mais au cœur
de  c'est exactement la même chose c'est
juste que les gens voient quelque chose de
différent
il y a des histoires sur ce qui s'est passé
c'est vrai
Oh
recommencez JJ a été très amusant je veux dire
qu'il est directeur d'accès et nous avons une
excellente chimie et lui quelqu'un a
définitivement été un grand  impact  t sur ma
carrière jusqu'à présent, j'adore travailler avec le
gars JJ Abrams est incroyablement passionné
et doué pour ce qu'il fait, il prend
ces phénomènes ces films gigantesques
et fait une famille des gens qui le
font et il le fait avec un tel
générosité de cœur et je pense que c'est
pourquoi ce film est aussi incroyable
car l'homme qui le dirige
est plein de passion et d'humanité dans Star
Wars 8 certainement beaucoup plus de Poe
potentiellement beaucoup plus de Finn ce
serait amusant je  pense qu'il serait bon de voir
plus d'exploration sur qui est cette
femme et comment elle est née comment
elle est née qui elle est dans la
position où elle est en tant que capitaine des
stormtroopers et je suis l'événement qui a
l'ont amenée à rejoindre le côté obscur et
aussi quelle est l'étendue de ses
pouvoirs c'est ce que j'aimerais voir ce que
j'aime dans l'expérience Star Wars,
c'est qu'elle est si interactive et pour moi
ce que j'attends avec impatience  dans le
futur est enfin ce film est  être
expérimenté par les fans et j'ai hâte de
voir ce qu'il adviendra de cela parce que c'est
un univers qui a tellement de plates-formes
de développement que
vous connaissez ces jeux et il y a des bandes
dessinées et il y a toutes sortes de façons
dont les gens commencent à interagir et à
peupler  le nouveau monde et j'ai
hâte de voir ce qu'il adviendra de ce
[Musique]
le Jedi du côté obscur
ils sont réels
la force qui t'appelle
[Musique]
juste betadine
toi
[Musique]